مشاهدينا نتحول مباشره الى مدينه سانتوس
لمتابعه هذه الصور المباشره لمراسم توديع
اسطوره كره القدم البرازيلي الراحل بيليه
حيث
الجماهير لالقاء نظره الوداع الاخيره على
جثمان بليه المسجل في نعش في وسط ملعب
سانتوس الذي بدا فيه مسيرته الرياضيه همم
بالتاكيد يوم غد سيجوب موكب جنائزي يحمل
جثمان بيليه شوارع سانتوس هو يتوجه بعد
ذلك الى المقبره حيث سيوار الثرى في مراسم
همم خاصه طبعا همم متوقع ان يحضر عدد من
المسؤولين همم البرازيليين لهذه المراسم
من بينهم الرئيس الجديد
لولا ده سيلفا ونائب الرئيس همم المعروف
بانه يشجع همم
نادي سانتوس طبعا رئيس الاتحاد الدولي
لكره القدم همم
انفنتينو كان من اوائل الواصلين الى
البرازيل لحضور
المراسم واا قال بانه سيطلب من كل دوله في
تصريحات له اطلاق سلبي ليه على احد
ملاعبها
تكريما ل همم من وصفوا بالرجل الوحيد الذي
فاز بكاس العالم ثلاث مرات همم كلاعب
طبعا الفانتينو ابلغ الصحفيين بانه خالد
وان ااا الفيفا سيممنح من وصفه الملك
التكريم الذي يستحقه وقال بانه طلب من
اتحادات كره القدم الوقوف دقيقه حداد قبل
كل همم مباراه
طبعا بيل توفي يوم الخميس الماضي عن عمر
82 عاما بعد صراعا مع سرطان القولون
نشير فقط
الالعاب الناريه الى سانتوس
وهذه المدينه يبلغ تعداد سكانها تقريبا
نحو نصف مليون 430,000 نسمه في صباح اليوم
قادم من مستشفى البرت اينشتاين في الطاوله
وهذه الصور تاتينا مباشره من قلب الملعب